hello everyone and welcome to one of the
nicest games from the final round of
this year's European individual
Championship sorry about a bit of a
lower volume uh on the the videos
yesterday I have no idea how that
happened I I didn't mess with any of the
settings uh so I really have no idea how
it happened but uh they're really sorry
about that yeah it's it's really
annoying when you have to you know uh
set the volume specifically for one
video and then uh return it for for the
other ones but what are you gonna do uh
here we have a very nice game between uh
Constantinople and Alexander donchenko
of Germany and we've seen yesterday how
lupuscu just destroyed the benoni
defense uh so here we're gonna see how
he does against the king's Indian
defense and
um it's it's a really wild wild game
very short one uh let's check it out so
uh Constantine has the white pieces he
opens with C4 we have Knight to have six
Knights the C3 G6 D4 and Bishop to G7
the king's Indian defense is on the
board we have E4 D6 Bishop to E2 and
here we have castles Bishop to E3 and
now usually E5 is played here but
usually I mean it's the main move here
has been played the most times and
um it definitely makes sense for black
but here we have Knight the C6 it's a
bit of a rare move and it's uh it's a
square that the Knight usually doesn't
see in the king's Indian defense because
after E5 you will probably see D5 and
then you will not have Knight to C6 but
here we get some very very cool
positions the Five Knights the E5 Ponte
F4 now challenges the night Knight eat
the G4 and Bishop to C1 you don't want
to give up the bishop pair so early
Knight to H6 and now Knight to F3 we
have Pawn to C6 challenging White Center
here and there is a game where Bishop to
D3 was played but here we have Pawn to
A4 by Constantine and it is now as of
move 11 that we have a completely new
game so C captures on D5 and here comes
e captures on D5 the the safer choice
will see captures on D5 this gives up
the df5 Square to the Black Knight but I
Constantin decides to try this way we
have Knights to F5 now immediately
grabbing that square A5 and now Pawn to
E6 with the captures an E6 Bishop
captures and now Knight to G5 putting
pressure on the bishop there Rook the E8
and here we have a trade on E6 captures
captures we have castles and now Queen
to C7 uh developing the queen preparing
to bring the other Rook into the game
Queen to D3 and now Rook a to E8 with
Bishop to F3 getting the bishop out of
this weird Square so
uh Bishop to F3 we have Pawn to H5 and
it looks like Black's position is uh
just just playing itself you know that
the Knight is coming on G4 and there
doesn't seem to be a good plan for white
king to H1 we have Knight to G4 sorry
not the G4 and now Bishop captures on G4
you should just continue developing here
but uh Constantine decided to capture we
have H captors and now Bishop to D2 but
now look at this beautiful diagonal it's
uh just inviting The Black Queen to go
in in for the attack we have Queen to
the eighth now going after Queen to H3 a
queen to H4 and while you could prevent
this with a move like uh G3 then you
open up this diagonal and it's not gonna
be any better so here Knight the D5 and
excellent Square for the Knight but this
is um far far away from the actual
action so Queen to H4 and now Bishop the
C3 countering black strong dark Square
Bishop we have Rook to E2 now and King
to G1 as G3 is coming so you don't wanna
have your HD H1 stack there so King to
G1 Bishop captures on c3b captures and
King to G7 now we have Rook 8 to B1 now
putting pressure on the B7 Pawn but now
just Rook the H A threatening mate in
one we have Ponte H3 and now G captures
an H3 Queen captures on H3 and it's a
much much better position for black
there are a couple moves that are very
strong but there is one move that uh
insists white uh just resigns
immediately so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute best
move for blank here while I give you a
couple of seconds
foreign
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting uh any of the cool moves
like Queen characters and H3 or even
Knight to G3 but for those of you who
found Queen to G3 congratulations as
this is instant resigned for white and
it was in fact in this position on move
29 that uh Constantinople resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here once you see what happens when
you trade Queens captures captures uh
you know that you see that there's no
defense against Rook to H1 check me
regardless of what white plays on the
next move Rook to H1 is black snacks
next move and that will be Checkmate and
if you don't capture the queen after
this G captures and uh Queen to G3 what
else are we playing The Queen Is
attacked by The Rook next move Rook will
just capture the queen and you don't
have a reply to this so of course Queen
G3 is instant resigns uh so yeah one of
the nicer games I I thought you guys
might enjoy from the from the final
round this uh fun line of the king's
Indian defensive or King's Indian
defense player yourself you might try
Knights the C6 here instead of E5 and
see how it goes you might get some very
active playable positions and you might
destroy your opponent like I like
Alexander did in this game so do give it
a go uh so yeah that's the game hope you
enjoyed it I would like to wish a very
happy birthday which was yesterday to Mr
Otto and I would like to thank Jill
Wilder Saran Kavanaugh Rob boshov and an
anonymous person for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and uh have an excellent rest
of your day